بالفعل في الدقيقه الثالثه والسبعين من
مباراه ريال مدريد التي خاضها الاحد امام
فالنسيا في الجوله 35 من الدوري الاسباني
اشتبك فينيسيوس جونيور لاعب المورينجي مع
جماهير الخصم التي ضلت تهتف ضده طوال
المباراه الفوضى اوقفت اللاعب نحو عشر
دقائق ولم يستانف اللعب حتى طالبت مكبرات
الصوت في ملعب مستايا بوقف هتافات
الكراهيه ما زاد الطين بالله طرد فينيسيوس
في الدقائق الاخيره من المباراه بعد تورطه
في شجار مع لاعب فالنسيا هوجودو بينما لم
يطرد الحكم اللاعب الاسباني وهو ما وصفه
معلقون بان الفار عنصري ايضا فينيسيوس نشر
بيانا على تويتر يقول فيه البطوله التي
كانت في احدى الايام ملكا لرونالدو وميسي
تنتمي اليوم للعنصريين كما وصف الطرد الذي
تحصل عليه في نهايه المباراه
بالهديه التي فاز بها ممارسوه العنصريه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات